also beginning this week c-span travels
along the route alexis de tocqueville
took in 1831 and 32 retracing the steps
of the author of democracy in america
we take a fresh look at the concepts he
wrote about and their relevance to
issues facing america today the alexis
de tocqueville tour exploring democracy
in america starting this friday may 9th
live from newport rhode island at 7 a.m
eastern here on c-span
this saturday on american perspectives
see a tour of president harry truman's
independence missouri office
that's saturday night at 10 40 eastern
end pacific
now a briefing on holocaust victims
assets
stuart eisenstadt heads the interagency
task force looking into nazi germany's
confiscation of gold and other assets
from individuals during world war ii
most were deposited into swiss bank
accounts
mr eisenstadt reviews a government
report concerning switzerland's wartime
economic ties with nazi germany and the
united states
and swiss post-war efforts to reclaim
the gold
thank you all for coming
i know many of you have awaited with
interest in patience the release of this
report
given the very important nature of the
issues at stake we felt that
it was important to spend the extra time
to make the report as complete and as
accurate as possible we're issuing today
a preliminary study entitled u.s and
allied efforts
to recover and restore gold and other
assets stolen or hidden by germany
during world war ii
the report was prepared by the state
department's chief historian dr william
slaney who
is with us today
dr slaney is a person of great
scholarship
of unimpeachable integrity
and of inordinate patients
and it's the product of an extraordinary
seven-month effort on the part of 11 u.s
government agencies
along with a selection of some 200
documents that we have here
to support our findings it also includes
a summary
and an interpretive forward presenting
my own conclusions
for this effort we have declassified and
transferred
to the national archives
between eight hundred thousand and one
million pages
the most at any one time in the history
of the national archives
including previously unavailable oss
army state treasury and justice
department records
we've also published a guide which we
have here
for scholars journalists
congress and the others
to all of the 15 million
or so pages of relevant documents
again we're told that this is the
largest such effort
ever undertaken using the records of the
national archives
we've worked feverishly since october
but let me emphasize that our report is
only preliminary
a full picture of the issues
and the events covered in our report
will ultimately depend
on the record of other countries and
further research through our own
materials
this report addresses a vital
but relatively neglected dimension of
the history of the second world war and
its aftermath
one that has become the focus of intense
political diplomatic and media attention
over the last year
it's a study of the past
but one that has real implications for
the future
the report documents one of the greatest
thefts
by a government in recorded history
the confiscation by nazi germany of an
estimated 580 million dollars
of central bank gold
which would be worth about 5.6 billion
dollars in today's values
along with indeterminate amounts of
other assets from individual victims
of nazi atrocities during world war ii
around 400 million dollars of this
looted gold
3.9 billion dollars in today's values
went to switzerland
either to the swiss national bank's own
account
or the account of other countries at the
swiss national bank
why the sudden surge of interest
in these events of five decades ago
there are a variety of explanations the
end of the cold war gave us the chance
to examine issues long pushed to the
background
many previously unavailable documents
have been declassified
aging holocaust survivors have an urgent
desire
to ensure that long-suppressed facts
come to light
before it is too late for them
and to see a greater degree of justice
to assuage however slightly
their sufferings
and younger generations also seek a
deeper understanding
of the most profound events
of the 20th century as we prepare to
enter the 21st
but in particular the courageous efforts
of edgar bronfman and israel singer of
the world jewish congress
of senator alfons d'amato of new york
together with a
bipartisan group in the congress
and president clinton's own strong
support
have touched the world's conscience
and prompted a search for the facts
our mandate from president clinton was
to describe to the fullest extent
possible u.s and allied efforts
to recover and restore gold and other
assets
stolen from governments and civilians
in the countries nazi germany overran
and the initially valiant but ultimately
inadequate steps
taken by the u s and its allies to use
these assets
for the assistance of stateless victims
of nazi atrocities
and the reconstruction of post-war
europe
we have done just what the president had
asked
and we've done it in unvarnished terms
this historical report represents a
search for facts
a quest for understanding and an effort
to set the record straight
it seeks neither to defend
nor to offend any nation
the countries mentioned in our report
are our friends and allies today and we
value their relationships
it seeks to clarify so we can move
forward
not to sensationalize
so as to assign blame
the picture which emerges from these
pages is often harsh
and unflattering
particularly when dealing with actions
and attitudes of the neutral countries
all profited from their economic
cooperation with nazi germany
among the neutral countries switzerland
receives the most attention in this
report
because of its crucial financial role
we have no desire
to single out a country switzerland that
is a robust democracy
a very generous contributor
to humanitarian efforts
and a valued partner of the united
states today
but the purpose and scope of this study
regarding nazi gold
means that swiss switzerland figures
prominently
the report also shines a bright light on
our own country's shortcomings
america's leadership during and
following the war was obviously
admirable and commendable
of course the war itself would not have
been won without the enormous u.s effort
in people and materiel
nor could the remarkable rebuilding of
europe have occurred without american
leadership
the u.s government took the lead in the
economic warfare against the axis powers
by initiating the safe haven program
together with our allies
the u.s scored significant successes in
blocking
german assets in leaving this country
and in tracking the flow of nazi assets
particularly looted gold
to prevent any nazi resurgence after the
war which was the very purpose of the
safe haven program
the u.s led the reconstruction of europe
through the mark remarkably generous and
successful marshall plan
the report however highlights united
states and allied failures
in the areas of restitution and
compensation during post-war
negotiations to retrieve
nazi assets
while this historical report simply lays
out the facts in an objective manner
there are certain inevitable conclusions
one can draw
and i've outlined my own personal
conclusions and the forward to the
report
the report should raise questions and
serve as a catalyst for further research
and action to redress however belatedly
some small measure of the injustice that
still weighs on so many people today
let me share with you the major
conclusions i have reached in my own
review as coordinator of this effort
first
the massive and systematic plundering by
nazi germany of gold and other assets
from conquered nations and victims was
no rogue operation
it was systematic
intentional
and essential to the financing of the
german war machine
and they used neutral countries as
banking and financial facilitators
with the reich mark largely unusable
in order to obtain war materials the
nazis used looted gold
shipped largely to switzerland
to convert into swiss francs
to help meet their war needs
the german central bank the reich bank
knowingly and willingly received gold
plundered from the central banks
of their
neighboring countries which the nazis
had overrun
and in addition
had a special account called the melmer
account
for the ss officer brumo melmer
for the deposit of jewelry watches and
even dental fillings of civilian victims
of the holocaust
the gold from monetary
and
non-monetary sources
was then smelted
or re-smelted
into gold bullion
and its origins often disguised with
false markings
this is a blow up
of one of the documents
from the precious metals department
records which we recently discovered
just within the last few weeks
from microfilm records at the archives
from the reichsbank
this is the
millmer account the name melmer
and this is on one day of one year
and the
translation
is on behalf of the reich finance
ministry
854 rings
one trunk of silver objects
one trunk of dental gold
29.996 grams
and this appears frequently
in right bank records
second
in the unique circumstances of world war
ii
neutrality collided with morality
too often being neutral provided a
pretext for avoiding moral
considerations
of course
neutrality was historically a
well-established principle international
law
smaller countries used it
to protect themselves
from the incessant number
of european wars
but the report makes painfully clear
that neutral countries argentina
portugal spain sweden
switzerland and until the last three
months of the war turkey
were slow to recognize and to
acknowledge that this was not just
another european war
most never did
nazi germany was instead a mortal threat
to western civilization
their cooperation was motivated
in part by fear of invasion
they were only a panzer division away
although this receded during the latter
stages of the war
it was also motivated in part by nazi
sympathies in some countries
and by a desire for profit in all
all help support and prolong nazi
germany's capacity to wage war
at a time of grievous allied
and civilian casualties
third
of all the neutral nations switzerland
had the most complex role
in world war ii
because of the financial role played by
the swiss national bank
and swiss commercial banks
it had the deepest
and most crucial economic relationship
with nazi germany
involving banking
trade industrial production
and the use of their railways
it like others
had reason to fear nazi attack indeed
was surrounded on all sides by axis
powers
at the same time
many of its actions benefited the allies
it bought substantial amounts of gold
and hard currency from the allies
it served as a protecting power for
allied pows and property
and provided a crucial intelligence base
for the oss
during the war
but without question
switzerland and other neutral nations
benefited from their trade and financial
dealings with the germans
and helped prolong the war effort
swiss actions after the war are the
least understandable
after the war despite appeals from
allied negotiators
to consider the moral imperative
the swiss demonstrated an oblate
reluctance to cooperate with allied
efforts to retrieve and redistribute
looted
gold despite repeated swiss
protestations after the war that they
had never received any looted nazi gold
this report is incontrovertible
the swiss national bank and swiss
bankers knew as the war progressed
that the reich bank's own coffers had
been depleted
and that the swiss were handling vast
sums of looted gold
in post-war negotiations
switzerland used legalistic positions to
defend their interests
regardless of the moral issues also at
stake
they first contended that they had
purchased nazi gold
in good faith and only later did they
admit to having obtained looted belgium
gold
after long difficult and contentious
bargaining agreement was reached in the
form of the 1946 washington accord
obligating the swiss to return 58
million dollars to the allies
far less
than the range of 185 to 289 million
dollars in looted gold
that the treasury and state departments
estimated was in swiss national
accounts the swiss were even less
forthcoming in implementing the other
part
of the washington accord
providing the allies with 50 percent
of the liquidated value of german assets
in switzerland after the war
both for the reconstruction of europe
and for the benefit of refugees
six years later in 1952
the allies accepted a token payment of
28 million dollars
in liquidated
value of german assets
compared to allied estimates
of 250 to 500 million dollars and this
chart
shows
that germany
looted
579 million dollars of gold during the
war that would be again about 5.6
billion
that around 400 million of it went to
switzerland and of that
between 185 and 289 million was for
their own account in looted gold the
rest was for the account of other banks
at the swiss national bank such as
portugal and spain
this is the amount and the range of
german external assets
at the end of the war in switzerland the
treasury estimated 500 million state 250
to 500 million the swiss delegation
itself 250 million press accounts 750
million the amount ultimately paid in
total
in 1952 was 28 million
even this amount was effectively paid
for by the german swiss settlement of
war debt between the two nations reached
at the same time
as the 1952 accord with the allies
until last year the swiss banks were
notably uncooperative in helping
identify dormant bank accounts
it's important to emphasize
that swiss was
not the exception
negotiation with most of the other
neutral countries spain portugal turkey
for example with the possible exception
of sweden
were also difficult were also
contentious were also prolonged
and also produced little
fourth
american leadership in the post-war
negotiations to retrieve nazi gold and
other assets was
clearly well-intentioned but
unfortunately limited
there was a demonstrable lack of senior
level administration support for a tough
and consistent u s negotiating position
with the neutrals
moreover there was an even greater lack
of attention
to ensuring the implementation
of agreements
already negotiated like the 1946
washington agreement
the reason is quite clear when one goes
through the report
and that is that wartime objectives were
replaced
by new cold war
imperatives
for example the berlin blockade in
june of 1948 emphasizes this
the need to rebuild post-war europe
the need to create nato to contain
the soviet threat
also putting a democratic west germany
on its feet
and other security concerns with all
neutral countries also took
precedence
fifth
the report concludes that some nazi
victim gold
was sent abroad to switzerland
and other neutral countries
and
that some
victim gold was also included
in the tripartite gold commission gold
pool
into which looted central bank gold
was placed for redistribution
to the governments from whom it was
stolen during the war
although there is no evidence that
switzerland or any other neutral country
knowingly accepted victim gold
the study also provides clear evidence
that at least a small portion of the
gold that entered switzerland and italy
included non-monetary gold from
individual citizens and occupied
countries
and from concentration victims or others
killed before they even reached the
camps
further research could determine
whether more was included
finally
one aspect of the study deserves
immediate attention and action
the plight of those who were victims not
only of war and the holocaust
but of the sad combination
of indifference on the part of neutrals
and inaction on the part of the allies
the report reveals serious inequities
developed in the treatment of victims
depending on where they lived after the
war whether behind the iron curtain or
in the west
beyond immediate emergency resettlement
assistance
most governments did not have long-term
commitments to rehabilitation of
individuals and thus the greatest burden
of providing ongoing relief fell on
private organizations
throughout this voluminous report it is
impossible to escape the conclusion
that the primary victims were those who
suffered the most during the war the
victims themselves
this alone should evoke
a sense of injustice
it is important therefore that we use
this opportunity and information to act
decisively
to complete the unfinished business of
the second world war
to do justice while its survivors are
still alive
that is why the united states favors
a substantial portion of the 70 million
dollars
still in the tgc gold pool
be voluntarily placed in an
international fund
for holocaust victims and other victims
of nazi atrocities
it is important that a healing process
begin
and the genuine reconciliation be
achieved
and here there is genuine reason for
optimism
especially with so many countries now
willing to honestly confront their past
and to draw lessons from it
following the landmark british study of
last year
and the launching of our own
study by the clinton administration
switzerland sweden
france
spain
norway the netherlands
belgium brazil and most recently
just within the last few days argentina
have established or will soon establish
historical commissions
to examine their roles in world war ii
their relationship with nazi germany
and their responsibility to return
looted property
in particular
we welcome and applaud
the steps switzerland has taken
in establishing
commissions to examine assets in dorman
bank accounts
and to review the entire historical
relationship between switzerland
and nazi germany
the swiss government
individual banks
swiss industry and private swiss
citizens even school children in
switzerland
are also demonstrating leadership
by establishing funds for victims of
nazi atrocities and other humanitarian
causes
to move this healing process forward it
is vital that all the facts be made
public
the clinton administration has made an
extraordinary effort to declassify
documents that may shed light on these
issues in addition
the u.s government favors the immediate
declassification
of all tripartite gold commission
documents
that bear on the origin
of the tgc gold pool
the united states will also explore the
idea of an international conference of
historians and other experts
this fall
to exchange information insights and
documents about the flow of nazi assets
the relationship with the third reich
during the war
and measures for finding surviving
owners
or disposing of airless property
the us and other concerned governments
would then need to assess the results of
these efforts
it will be important for example to have
complete german reich bank records
available
so that we can all reach a more complete
understanding of the origin and flow of
these looted assets
we hope that other governments will
continue to build on these hopeful
beginnings
we all need to pursue unresolved issues
such as the disposition of airless
assets including
any which may remain in the united
states
we must all look for ways to assure that
needy survivors particularly the double
victims
of both the war
and communism are cared for and
compensated
much
work remains but this preliminary study
is a major step forward
ultimately the united states
our allies and all of the neutral
nations
should be judged not so much
by the actions or inactions of a
previous generation
but by what we do today and by our
generation's willingness
to face the past honestly
to help right the wrongs
and to deal with the injustices suffered
by the victims of nazi aggression
our hope is that this study will advance
that purpose thank you and i'll take
your questions
in your view
neutral countries say like portugal
that
have not been proven to have received
a goal that was personal property of the
victims of the holocaust but
nevertheless returned only a small
fraction of rooted goal
do they still have
a moral obligation to make reparations
to the victims of the holocaust
we document in this study the fact that
uh
looted gold was in the possession
of portugal of spain of turkey uh as
well as of uh switzerland uh and indeed
of sweden as well after the war as our
report indicates the negotiations which
i have to emphasize the allies willingly
participated in
clearly did not
provide a full
return
in some cases not even a significant
return of that goal
turkey for example had uh at the end of
the negotiations promised a one million
dollar payment nothing was ever paid
to this day so i think each country
needs to examine this record
and through its own historical
recommendations
and make its own judgments but i think
that these facts
speak very loudly
and i would again hold out switzerland
as an example of a country which has
tried to rectify the past to begun to do
so and this is something i think other
countries might do as well yes
sorry let me clarify just one smaller
when you say looted gold is it also
non-monetary goals
we don't have
substantial evidence of victim's goal
going to other
countries other than sweden and italy
but
it's very important to understand
that because of the way in which the
reich banks smelted and re-smelted both
central bank gold and victim's jewelry
and poured it into new ingots and then
disguised it
that
distinguishing between by appearance
victims and non-victims gold was
impossible to do
it was the clear pattern and practice of
the rife bank as shown by these accounts
to intermingle these and ship these
abroad
where they may have landed and the
amounts is difficult to say but it seems
quite clear
that victim gold was incorporated into
these ingots and would have perhaps been
in all of the neutral countries mr
eisenstadt you've noted that uh that in
the agreement that the swiss made with
the allies at the end uh for 58 million
dollars in payments on the monetary side
uh and on the other side the german
assets that the allies are supposed to
get 50 of the the swiss have
on both sides they really have not paid
the money that they had they have not
acknowledged the the german assets that
they had
first of all do you favor reopening
the negotiations that led to that
agreement
and do you favor any other steps now
that you've done all this research
to try and bring a greater measure of
justice
at this point we
neither
exclude or
include the possibility of reopening
that agreement
we think it's important that the reports
stand for itself at this point that all
the countries involved
including switzerland look at it examine
it determine its credibility
and act accordingly so at this point we
have not made a judgment as to whether
or not
we should reopen that negotiation it is
important however again for all of the
neutral countries
to look at their their role
and the very small amounts that were
returned relative to what they actually
possessed
i think it's also important to
understand however as i've emphasized
that the us and the allies were part and
parcel of these negotiations
they documented the amount of gold that
was available in each of these countries
they documented the amount of nazi
assets
and because of
post-war considerations simply did not
want to press the countries as much as
they might have and it's also important
to understand
the us unblocked swiss assets in the
united states
almost immediately after signing the
1946 agreement over the objection of the
treasury department for example
and this lost a good deal of negotiating
leverage
it's also important to understand as we
point out for example with with portugal
there were serious negotiations for
access
to
the azores air force base that was
clearly a consideration
even with respect to switzerland there
was a 1951 decision by the national
security council
announced by president truman signed off
by president truman
that even though it was recognized
switzerland would remain neutral
that it was an essential democratic
deterrent
to soviet expansion this was also a
factor and last
it's quite clear as one reads through
the pages that
the allied and us negotiators realized
that at least in part if not in whole
germany
would be funding
part of these agreements
that is to say
that each of these neutral countries had
large outstanding debts owed by the
germans for wartime shipments
of everything from ball bearings to
raw materials
cobalt chrome and the light
they wanted that money back from the
germans
despite the fact that it had helped
prolong the war
and the allies realized that in the end
the germans were going to be paying for
part of this by paying this the neutrals
who would then in turn
uh
return the compensation and there was a
desire not to overburden
the post-war german economy at a time
when west germany was being incorporated
back into the allied countries bob you
um at the outset of your remarks you
said that this report has real
implications for the future i'm
wondering specifically if one of those
implications perhaps is a message to
switzerland
concerning other hidden assets
at the moment for example that might be
held by mubutu and various names
and also what are the some of the other
implications for the future that this
report holds
well some of the implications i've
already mentioned what to do with the
documents of the tripod tag gold
commission
what to do with the remaining 70 million
dollars
how to get a
formal accounting
uh the need
for cooperation which the swiss are
certainly doing
in the volcker commission study
the need for other countries to come to
terms
with their past but we certainly hope
that this will
occasion a broader look at the whole
issue of transparency international
transactions
so that we don't
again
face anything like we've faced here
uh that will pertain to each particular
country in different ways but i think
the the last thing bob that i would say
is that the swiss again have led the way
here
in terms of initiating uh the
commissions and funds
it's important for the other neutral
countries as well
to look at their record and what they
did and come to terms with their own
past and to act on those lessons as the
swiss have begun to do
how do you recommend that the remaining
assets be distributed
because compensation to holocaust
victims and what form should that take
it's important to recognize that of the
70 million dollars
left and these figures become confusing
when we talk about today's values so let
me
give you a better sense of what we're
actually talking about and then we can
answer the question directly
the
tripartite gold commission
has paid out about 379
million dollars
in
monetary gold although again we now
believe some of that was non-monetary
gold about four billion dollars in
today's values
that represented a payment back to the
10 claimant countries from whom was
stolen
of
329 metric tons
that leaves
today about 5.6
million metric tons
or in today's values
just under 70 million dollars
roughly 4 million of those metric tons
are in the bank of england
worth about 46 million dollars
and around two million metric tons two
two metric tons
worth about 22 million dollars are in
the new york federal reserve bank
so this is what we're dealing with
now
this would require
unless one were to renegotiate the
entire post-war agreement which would
take the consent of every country
voluntary contributions
by the countries
what we have suggested
is that a substantial portion
of that 70 million dollars be put into a
fund for victims
it's important to understand i think
that about four countries
have claim on ninety percent
of that
seventy million dollars in gold
and
that distributed amongst
even those four let alone all ten
70 million dollars is a pittance
for uh countries but it could be of
significant help
to those aging survivors who this report
makes clear did not receive
anything close to the justice they they
might have and so this will require
voluntary action
uh and we hope that uh
an appeal to their conscience plus
plus the fact that this record is now
clear that some of that gold in that
pool and therefore some of the gold
distributed did include victim gold
although we can't quantify it
how would you then
suggest distributing that 70 million
that'll obviously be something if it can
be accumulated itself
that we'll have to determine the whole
organization of such a fund uh who the
appropriate victims are we certainly
feel
that the ones who have the strongest
call on the conscience and we say so
are those double victims
that is those who were trapped behind
the iron curtain
after world war ii
and have essentially gotten nothing from
the german government unlike those who
emigrated to the west
uh israel united states other countries
who have gotten uh over 80 billion
dollars in deutsche marks these people
have essentially not been paid to this
day by the german government yes how
many people do you estimate that would
be and what are the four countries that
lay claim to the 70 million
first of all
in terms of those so-called double
victims
one would estimate somewhere in the
range of 30 to 50 000
uh probably closer to 50 but
something in that range
and here again i want to indicate
that this whole effort
is beginning to have an almost cleansing
impact on countries and and a positive
impact that there is room
for real optimism
hungary is a perfect example of a
country that is
leading the way in central europe for
its double victims
beginning this very month
a foundation has been been created in
hungary with the cooperation of the
hungarian government the hungarian
jewish community and the world jewish
restitution organization
and this could be a potential model
for the way in which funds might be
allocated more broadly
they that fund will
be the repository for the restitution of
real property that belonged uh to uh the
jewish community then
uh church synagogues and the schools and
community centers and the like but also
they will begin paying between twenty
and forty dollars a month
uh to over twenty thousand of their
survivors we know that
uh around half of all the survivors in
central europe uh are in hungary and
that gives us a basic uh calculus that
we're talking around again somewhere
between 30 and 50 000.
yes
shows how close the relations were
between switzerland and germany at that
time was it by mutual sympathy for
financial
interest or just not for switzerland not
to be invaded by germany
it was a combination of factors
and one of the things we've done as
shown by my uh
preface and i think that
the report
makes this very clear we try to divide
our analysis of
neutral country conduct not only
switzerland but the other countries who
also significantly contributed to the
war effort into three phases the first
phase was from the outbreak of world war
ii in 1939 to roughly uh 1943 the battle
of stalingrad when the
during that period german war prowess
was the greatest and fear of invasion
certainly by switzerland which was the
closest uh was quite legitimate
the second period
would be from the
time of the
allied invasion of italy
d-day
and the continuing advance of soviet
armies from the east
when the threat
of german invasion receded substantially
and uh indeed almost evaporated toward
the end of the war and third is the
post-war conduct
and uh it is the post-war conduct in a
sense that again
uh is the least uh explainable and and
the most difficult to understand because
some of the
behavior that was seen during the war
continued uh well into the post-war
period
yes yes you said that the
agreements between switzerland the
united states of 46 and 50
two
obviously were not satisfactory that
the payments the payments
made by the swiss obviously uh
did not not in any way match the
estimates of
the obligations made on the u.s side on
the other hand the swiss government has
decided to set up a
foundation
which should yield something like
300 million
swiss francs a year for humanitarian
purposes
in in the view of the us government or
in your personal view is this action uh
if it's accepted by the people in the
referendum would that be sufficient
perhaps to
close the gap in
moral
obligation which seems to
be outstanding and left after the 46 and
52 agreement
well first i think it's important to
understand what the swiss have actually
done they have now set up
through the private sector the three
major swiss banks
but not by any means all of the swiss
banks the swiss national bank
and some of the major companies
a fund which is now roughly 180 million
dollars and and growing
this is a private sector fund it will
begin operations very shortly uh on both
the american and
u.s sides excuse me the american and
swiss sides people are already being
named to that
the second fund as you indicate will
depend on an act of the swiss parliament
and perhaps
a referendum although this is still to
be determined
in which the swiss have set aside into a
reserve 4.7 billion dollars
which will throw off several hundred
million dollars for general humanitarian
causes not simply the holocaust but for
general problems of poverty and other
humanitarian causes this is obviously an
important step forward
i think it's important that as
switzerland and the other neutrals
examine this report and its implications
they begin to look at the question of
whether this is a sufficient
response
and that's why we wanted this report to
stand for itself so countries had a
chance to absorb it
we think it's certainly an important
first step
whether it is the only step which should
be taken is something that uh will bear
further examination tyler
the report stresses the fact that uh in
the late 40s that
the legal challenge seemed uncertain uh
towards the swiss and the appeal was
made largely on moralistic grounds uh in
light of
the ensuing years and the evidence that
you've turned up
is there now a stronger basis for a
legal challenge is that an avenue
well first i certainly don't want to
start commenting on on class actions and
and the like i think that
at the end of the day it is important
that there be a closure
uh to this issue i don't think that
we're there now and as i've indicated
all countries need to look at this
report and determine what they ought to
be doing
but i don't want to get tyler into legal
arguments what i would say is is this
the legal question
involved was the question
uh which the allies had some doubts
about and it undoubtedly affected our
negotiating positions
was the question of whether there was
legal authority
in the allies to claim as the victorious
powers control over german
assets
both inside and outside of germany there
was an allied control
declaration that was made shortly after
the war in which the allies made that
assertion
they felt it was obviously sustainable
in international law
but that was a
a question that was was asked
that is quite separate from the issue of
whether or not for example there is a
legal basis to now indicate that there
was victim's goal
mixed into the goal that went into the
tgc pool
where now it's clear that the
what we think a substantial portion of
that should be paid is not just based on
a moral argument but on the fact that
that was legally
to be gold that was monetary goal to
return to the central banks from whom it
was taken to the extent that there was
mixed into an individual gold
then that would have been an
inappropriate distribution uh i wonder
if dr slaney on the on the international
legal issue if you would like to
make any comments on
on the
question of where this what was in the
mind of the negotiators as you looked at
this and i think dr slaney has a very
keen understanding as a state department
for a story enough all the factors that
went into the allied
uh review of the uh
uh the negotiating posture and you might
they'll give your own thoughts about
that
uh in each step in the negotiations both
at the heads of government meeting at
potsdam and at the paris reparations
conference
and then the allied control authority in
germany in 1945
the question arose and was debated as to
whether or not
those allies who had conquered germany
could thereby assume
all authority for becoming a german
government and never was a unanimity it
is true that a law was adopted by the
allied control authority and that the
allies negotiating with the neutrals all
adopted the view in general that
that they had the authority to to claim
uh
to be the government of germany there
always was
there always were misgivings and there
was a consciousness
in past international law that it was
difficult to make such a claim it was in
a sense a rather unprecedented one
and one which uh throughout the
negotiations uh troubled negotiators and
probably as uh
secretary eisenstein has said uh
vitiated the force of their negotiations
you might just talk broadly about the us
and allied sort of thoughts during the
negotiations too in terms of the
post-war objectives
it is the case that um
the allies both at the wartime
conferences
and in the post-immediate post-war
period
were most concerned about the
reconstruction of europe
devastated by the germans
the
principal motive was to to find the
wherewithal immediately to try to begin
the restoration
of europe and to secure the
refugees whose presence in the occupied
area was too painful to
for anyone not to not to be terribly
conscious of them so these negotiations
were always written with the question
about the urgency of trying to
to
rebuild europe and to support the
refugees and the issue of whether or not
there was a legal basis for claiming
this or whether or not there was a moral
obligation
was for those negotiators always over
overshadowed by the more
palpable
issue about
doing something with a devastated
continent and
hundreds of thousands of people who were
without means and this was
this was an issue which always was
was in their minds and was only partly
uh
vitiated eventually by the establishment
of the marshall plan i would say also
one thing we haven't touched on that
underscores bill's point is the issue of
airless assets there were sad letters to
the 1946 washington accord
in which for example the swiss agreed to
to examine sympathetically
the issue of
taking airless assets in swiss banks
and giving them to the survivors
families or for other humanitarian
purposes
that was really never fully implemented
in 1962 there was a very
small
accounting
but otherwise those airless assets
really were never
adequately accounted for
yes
after this report um do you have
a better idea and so could you tell us
the amount of
uh assets of holocaust survivors
that remains
today
in swiss banks which after all was the
point
of this whole study
well first of all that was not the point
of the study that is the point of the
volcker commission which is to examine
that and they have two certified public
accounting firms
uh which are looking at that the swiss
have themselves
after first uh indicating in the
immediate post warrior that they had
none in 1962 found 2 million and they
now say that there are some 38 million
although we don't know that that was all
holocaust victims the whole purpose of
the volcker
commission report and study and the
analysis by the accounting firms is to
determine just that they're looking at
over 100 banks
they hope by the middle of this year to
have a preliminary audit done and by the
middle of next year to complete that and
i think we should await their uh their
findings rather than to try to speculate
i'd like to ask you a personal question
if i may
um to what extent did you have much
awareness
of all of this prior to becoming
involved in this very historic study
and ultimately how has it affected you
once you've been involved in it both as
a jew
and as an american
well first of all i had a government job
to do i was assigned to do a government
job and i did it the way i've tried to
do all the jobs i've been assigned since
my days with the carter white house
which is the best most objective and
fairest way i can i went into that with
uh with this
as well and and that means cold
objectivity
letting the facts with respect to the
role of the neutrals and the us
fall where they may as we were asked
at the same time
and i'll let uh perhaps dr selene speak
for this as a professional historian
who's gone through
cataloging war records and many other
things
i think as a individual and a human
being all of us were affected by what we
saw and what we read
the enormity of the crimes committed by
the germans and it's important when we
look at this it was the nazi it was nazi
germany not the neutrals who
committed the holocaust and looted this
goal
certainly came
to mind i don't think any of us will
ever be quite the same
for having gone through this
it really punctuated for us
the brutality of the war and the
importance of making sure
that everything is done to provide
justice to those who are still surviving
and i think that comes through not
simply in my own personal report but in
the summary and in the uh findings uh
that that we all made here i don't think
anyone can go through this without
some a feeling of emotion but at the
same time we never let that emotion
cloud our judgment we never
tried to come to conclusions that were
not warranted by the facts and we ne
never leaped over uh uh assumptions in
order to come to uh certain findings we
never let ourselves be pressured into
making certain uh decisions because it
might or
might not offend or support a particular
position uh bill do you want to just
talk on you you've gone through this as
a historian and many other things in
terms of
the uniqueness perhaps of
my own impression as a historian and i'm
speaking now
not only for myself but for the 25 or 30
colleagues in various agencies who
worked with me
so closely and whose work this actually
is rather than mine is that what we've
discovered
is that
the cold war
swept away
in many ways
and left unfinished
a whole world of problems and
difficulties and we in trying to uncover
these re-examine these matters
discovered how much was left undone from
50 years ago
and how much
has yet to be examined and i have to
spoken
often to
secretary eisenstein that what we've
done is only a road map
through
millions of pages of documents and i've
spoken to
my colleagues in other foreign office
historical programs in number of
countries and they're experiencing the
same thing there's a lot
that has yet to be examined there's a
lot that we don't understand it is
simply a case of
of having looked back over five decades
and discovered that much was left undone
and has yet to be addressed
this in fact was not your personal area
of expertise prior to getting involved
in this how were you personally affected
by
having gone through this undertaking
this study
well as a matter of fact
uh it is something that the state
department's foreign relations series
dealt with
25 and 30 years ago it is my regret
in in taking up the study that we hadn't
done it very thoroughly
uh it was a discovery that we hadn't
understood even ourselves in the 1960s
and 1970s when we published these
records originally
some of them that we hadn't thought
through and hadn't understood the
implications
of
what we were dealing with which
implications
that is one question concerning the
washington agreement
what could be uh reasons for a reopening
of this agreement one might conclude
from your report that already then it
was considered some sort of a compromise
again i think that uh our view is that
we don't want to get into the issue now
of whether it should or should not be
open we're not
in any way excluding that but we're not
suggesting that it should either
i think that it's important that
all the countries involved in the
washington accord
examine the record look back on it with
a very cold and objective light
and determine whether or not now 50
years later
all that all has been done that might
have been done
at the time uh i think the facts and
conclusions are rather evident and
obvious
but the way in which and what that leads
us to i think is for
another day secretary could you address
the question of victims gold how much do
you think uh landed in the melner
account um
also why don't you have the uh all of
the records of the reichsbank uh now
and how much of it was then dispersed
either to the tgc at the end of the war
or during the war to
neutrals such as switzerland
the
quantification of the amount of victim
gold that went into the tgc account
is not at this point capable of
determination perhaps with more records
we'll be able to find it but it may be
that we'll never fully
know the amount certainly it was a it
was a considerable sum
relative to the amount of monetary gold
from central banks it was a relatively
small amount
but for those from whom it was taken it
was obviously their life's uh savings
and and work
and valuables
and we have determined absolutely
specifically
uh that not only based on the pattern
and practice
of reich bank uh transactions and this
intermingling of monetary and
non-monetary gold
but from an analysis of prussian mint
smelting of looted dutch gilders from ss
victims
we know that some of that went abroad to
switzerland italy
we also know
from
other reports
and from the fact that some ss loot from
victims including gold coins
and bars were transferred by the allies
into the gold pool
there's also a question although we need
more information on this
about gold from
the nazi concentration camp of teresa
all of these uh
indicate
that victim gold was included and
therefore was redistributed but we do
not know the amounts
now in terms of the reich bank records
it's only within the last few weeks that
we really began to examine those the
reason being
that we had some 15 million pages of our
own documents
this is one of the reasons why we're
suggesting the possibility of an
international conference
we did find
after a great deal of examination that
we had
partial records
on microfilm
in the treasury department of reif bank
records and we discovered that only a
few weeks ago
those will be uh very important these
are part of the analysis this blow up
what seems to be missing
uh is that portion of the records
representing the full accounting of the
melmer ss
account
we have uh
very very clear indications
uh and bill correct me if i'm incorrect
here but we have very clear indications
from even the army
person who transferred
these uh records after they were given
to the united states for copying
and then transferred them back
uh that he that that this person did
deliver these particular records
uh
initially the rife bank said it's not
been able to identify those but they
certainly have not
uh at this point made a a full uh
examination and it will be very
important to get those
ss
account records from the reif bank and
i'm sure that they'll be cooperative try
to uh or did you did you look through
the files to see if reichsbank officials
who not only survived the war some of
them went to switzerland some of them
may have even stayed in germany
were ever uh deposed and and questioned
about this particular thing
they were deposed um i believe bill it
was mr poole
the vice
the vice chair
of the reich bank who provided very
crucial information to the army
uh after the uh after the war
it's also important in terms of getting
a sense of the that these are not dry
figures to just understand
the army almost uh inadvertently landed
on
this because the reich bank and the
closing weeks of the war transferred
almost all of their reserves into a salt
mine called the merker's mine
and as the allies swept through
germany
and the closing days of the war they
discovered in this salt mine
the this enormous uh gold pool
from reich bank records
and it's there that they found
the melmer account
it's there that they found
sacks
and box loads
of
victim gold identified by particular
concentration camps
and then in interviewing bill mr poole i
think it was
and others about the practice that they
had it was determined that this
re-smelting
operation was occurring both with
respect to central bank gold from the
other countries to disguise its origin
and to convert into usable tradable form
the victim's goal that uh this was
discovered bill do you want to add
anything on that
what were the four countries that you
say have claims on the uh uh tripartite
gold well there are 10 countries that
have claims
but uh the the countries that have i
think the the biggest claims are france
um
austria
the netherlands
and italy and how much of the 70 million
uh you said this twice that a
substantial portion of that 70 million
should be put in a account for survivors
or victims
can you be a little bit more specific
now we use that term because we want to
be able to uh discuss with our
allies
and the claimant countries the amounts
that ought to be done this has to be
done voluntarily
if we're going to do it in any
reasonable period of time to help the
survivors
we have stated our view we're not trying
to
pin other countries at this point to
to our negotiating position but that
that is our view
and we hope substantial means genuinely
a substantial amount of that and again i
think there's both a legal and a moral
basis and that this report helps
establish the legal basis for that
in examining
how much of this victim's gold may have
gone uh to switzerland either through
some kind of official way or even fenced
again because we can't quantify the
amount of victim gold we can't determine
what we do know is that some amount went
yes i think switzerland neutrality
during the war did you i mean is it
was there any comparison between the
amount of
money um and transactions switzerland
was handling for nazi germany
and the transactions it was handling for
for the allies
uh the swiss uh in fact uh bought very
substantial amounts by one uh
indication of the swiss national bank
they actually may have purchased more
gold from the allies than they did from
germany
uh and there was also some limited trade
although most of the trade was with uh
with germany okay one last question here
thank you
to follow on the non-military gold used
in the reports that states that there's
no evidence that switzerland italy knew
about the fact that there was
non-military gold but what is your
impression as an historian and yourself
mr eisenstein do you think that it's
possible that switzerland knew about it
i mean what
well again there is no question that
switzerland knew despite their initial
protestations of the country after the
war
uh there's no question that they knew
that there was looted gold we have
certainly uncovered no evidence that
they knew that it was victim's goal we
have no way of of making any judgment
beyond the fact that we have no evidence
in that respect and that the gold was
basically by
uh
by its appearance indistinguishable and
in again unfortunately the us definition
of non-monetary versus monetary goals
for tgc purposes was based on appearance
and not origin so all we can say is we
have no evidence
that would indicate that they knew it
was victims gold but there is clear
evidence they knew
that it was looted gold thank you very
much
you